i do have to ask you about another
moment in the premiere the only thing i
know about kaylee came from natori's
mouth because i was on broadway with her
and what she told me was
keeley threw a bucket of chicken at her
that's all i know about this girl
she throws buckets of chicken she's a
chicken bucket thrower can you set the
record straight what's your side of the
story there
i can't comment too much on that because
we do touch on that
on the show we definitely talk a lot
about our experiences and our former
girl group so
tune in to watch you'll be able to kind
of get my perspective
and all the other women's perspective it
was kind of like a
red table talk about all of our
collective traumas
um in girl groups and experiences um
but i do know that and aubrey has told
me you know
that that's been said before i it's it's
nothing new
i did not throw a bucket of chicken at
her so
i mean that that's as far as i can go
without
giving too much away it will all be
revealed
throughout the course of the show can i
ask where your relationship with natori
stands today were you guys able to make
peace or or make amends at some point no
i do not speak to natori
in the show you touch on your past and i
celebrate you as a proud member of both
3lw and the cheetah girls
and you know i know you're still very
close with sabrina
but i know that there's a complicated
history there with adrian who you were
very close with for many years where do
you and adrian stand today
i also do not speak to adrian all of the
the nature adrian thing is kind of all
like kind of mixed up in together and
not to say that i would
lump them in as the same person i think
it's unfortunate that
after all of these years and all the
success that they've been
able to achieve that they wouldn't use
their platforms to be more honest about
really what happened with the group um
but that's life you know
i don't really speak or think about them
i don't
watch daytime television i don't have
stars so
it doesn't really come up in my daily
life i know you now have a daughter
and for me as a young kid growing up i
looked at groups like the cheetah girls
like 3lw as
the epitome of women's empowerment
and i mean is there any part of you that
that
would or could consider a reconciliation
down the road what would that
take um well i i definitely think the
cheetah girls is
is probably the the avenue that it would
be just because
regardless of like past history everyone
is so professional
i mean there is a healthy amount of ego
there but i really think that
we all approach the cheetah girls from a
really professional standpoint so i
i think that that is more likely
also participating in the cheetah girls
felt
good because you were inspiring young
women
you got to see six-year-old kids and and
their eyes light up i mean
it was just such a fulfilling experience
i can't see all the women
saying no to that just because of how
good i know it made
all of us feel so yeah you never know
where would your character be today what
would you want to do if you rebooted it
i hope that aqua is married to kevin 347
living in a palace in india right now
i that i'm hoping ah would be living her
very best
indian palatial life
i would never try to hurt you like on
purpose well i appreciate that
sweetheart and i
release any pain towards you that i have
and i cancel clear and delete it
it was really emotional as a viewer to
watch you
on instagram live with raven simone it
kind of seemed like you guys had a
moment of healing
was that therapeutic for you absolutely
um and even though it was done in a
public forum i think
that kind of made it easier for us to
just kind of lay it all out there but i
think sometimes when you're put on the
spot
when there are people watching you
really can't like think of a good excuse
or think of a good lie so i think it was
a really honest conversation
that we had and honestly
like i said to her on the live i had no
idea that she felt the way that she felt
that's horrible for anyone to feel like
that why would i want anyone to feel
that way
but again for me like she was the
executive producer of our movie like how
could she be bullied you know
so kind of understanding that no matter
what a position a person's position
of power is they can still have those
feelings of insecurity
was really humbling for me because i
always you know felt
like she was raving you know and then
hearing her have that experience
was really like wow you know all this
time i'm thinking
you know she's our boss she's got all
this she's got all that
but she you know wanted to be with us
and like that
that's so sad and i i wish that would
have been
you know spoken about when we were there
i think
really what i took away from it was you
know hearts and minds
change you know we get older you know we
get wiser
we look back on things and and we don't
see them in the way that we did when we
were children
and you know when you're young and
you're in the middle of things
you're not always looking at you're not
looking at things from other people's
perspective
and i think that you know had we been
the age we are now i don't think any of
that would have happened i think we
would have been able to be more open and
honest with each other and
you know her to tell us how she felt so
that we can be like oh my god no
we want you to hang out with us
you don't want to be in a group you're
obviously not creative director so what
are you a
starter b-e-t presents the encore
you've kind of been living behind the
camera for the last decade or so
it seems like you're really happy you've
got your husband and your baby girl
what was it about this project that you
were like i'm ready to come out of
retirement
and let's do this the original
attraction to the project was
how much i hate the stigma that girl
groups can't stay together
and even though i'm pretty negative
about the probability of girl groups
staying together
i still have this like if i can only
find the right formula like it's like
this puzzle that i want to solve in my
mind
if i can only just figure out like the
right personality types the right
circumstance like
what could make it work because women
can work together in every other
industry in the world and it just seems
like
girl groups it's like something always
happens and there's drama
and infighting and all that stuff and i
just wanted to dispel that myth
because i don't believe it's true i i
really do think that if women come
together
working towards a common goal we can do
absolutely anything and i am really
grateful for the friendships that i've
made on the show
i'm grateful for even the fights and all
that stuff because all of those things
were teaching me things about myself
you know and i think that that's what
you get to see
24 hours a day it's more like big
brother than any other kind of like
reality show with celebrities you know
they're
robos there's cameras everywhere you
know um there was a microphone in our
bathrooms
so you know like no privacy no days off
and you really give the fans
and and the viewers a firsthand look at
what it takes to
really build a group from
the bottom up with that i've gotta ask
who did you bond with the most and who
did you clash with the most
i definitely faced a lot of resistance
from
a lot of the women specifically in the
um i think
in the first episode from the twins it
was very
hard at first to kind of just like
unclench your fists and be like we're
all here
for a reason we are all worthy we can
all do this
you know like let's just unclinch the
fists
and and try to get down to work and so
really that's mainly
my running theme i think for a while
it's just like
simmered out everybody stop yelling at
me i haven't even had a drink yet
i didn't even put my purse down and they
were coming it was crazy
we see there's like a really harrowing
moment where you say
i'm out goodbye i'm out bye
come out bye i know you can't reveal
much but can you tease like did you
quit what happened there there were a
lot of
moments where i felt
why am i here i could be home i could be
with my baby i could be living my
very happy life in relative obscurity
you know i don't need this
um and i think you know everybody kind
of has those moments and that's
that's when you know that you're
changing for 30 days i pretty much
no matter what happened the night before
woke up the next morning and tried again
tried harder i definitely felt
tested tried yeah um pressured
pressed and i i don't like to argue i'm
not like a
confrontational person in that way um a
lot of people are like oh she's gonna
read people and all that and
i don't really do that i nev i didn't
even do that in that leaked clip
that got the show i've been in two
multi-platinum successful groups and
i've been they weren't disbanded
and i've been the biggest one and
they're still together i know but you
weren't in it
i wasn't saying anything i kind of just
let other people talk and
like if you sound crazy i mean that's
what you do there were definitely
moments where i was like
this is a lost cause i feel like pretty
much every one of my confessionals i was
just like
this is never gonna work i think it's
never gonna happen
okay so i almost quit
um no i never almost quit i don't think
that
that that wasn't even in my like mind it
was like
questioning like am i getting paid
enough for this
i do remember like saying something like
they're gonna have to drag me out of
this house
by my wig and even then they'll just be
holding on to the wig i will still be in
the house
definitely determined to keep you know
to keep this going because i felt like
you know it's been something we've been
working on for seven years
um you know and so i felt a definite
like desire to see it through to the end
you